au pierre laporte jeu rassuré tout le
monde y est sécuritaire actuellement
même s'il se fait rassurant le premier
ministre est surpris des révélations de
l'émission enquête sur l'état des
suspentes du pont pierre laporte
françois bonnardel qui est ministre des
transports a pris il y à l'existence de
ce rapport c'est quand même surprenant
en train de faire une enquête comme sfax
est pas venu sur son bureau avant
radio-canada a recueilli le témoignage
de lanceurs d'alertés obtenu un rapport
qui nous apprend que les câbles
verticaux qui soutiennent le tablier du
pont sont de moins en moins résistants
un document de plus de 100 pages signée
par deux ingénieurs qui a été déposée le
21 avril il recommande le remplacement
de toutes les suspentes le plus tôt
possible
moi je trouve inacceptable d'avoir
d'avoir est un format la dernière et que
vous ayez des formules avant moi le
ministre des transports confirme que le
remplacement de tous ces câbles va être
accéléré le ministère prévoyait un
remplacement une consolidation des
suspens 266 prochaines années vous
assurer une chose aujourd'hui ça reprend
moins 15 ans pour consolider au départ
ou remplacer suscite est un lanceur
dallaire qui tout juste dévoilé les taux
de de l'infrastructure c'était pouvant
atteindre les présidents du syndicat des
ingénieurs du gouvernement créent
maintenant une chasse aux sorcières au
sein du ministère des transports on va
de plus de formes aussi trouver qui a
divulgué la vérité plutôt que me des
retraites des réels efforts pour
renforcer l'expertisé pas aller chercher
plus d'experts faire plus de travaux
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous on
this apprend un nouveau lien au plus
cher qu'un rapidement le maire de lévis
a sauté sur l'occasion pour remettre le
sujet du troisième lié à l'avant plan
alors que le maire de québec demandent
plutôt au ministère des transports de
donner l'heure juste soyons besoin de
sous aux besoins de cette démonstration
avec des données probantes de ce qui va
être fait et de quelle analyse on fait
si nécessaire le pont pierre laporte à
52 ans et 15 de ses 160 suspentes ont
été remplacés jusqu'à maintenant ici
marie pierre bouchard radio canada
québec